bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
peace be unto you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
Wednesday's Midnight's Thursdays at 2
p.m. if you're in Chicago can TV 36
where people from all around the globe
tune into the Deen show calm we're we're
here trying to help you understand Islam
and Muslims and when I come back we're
gonna be talking to my good friend Abdul
Rahim green he has his own section there
on the Deen show you can read a little
bit about him here his story on how he
came to Islam to the submission is
surrendered to the one God and other
topics that we have with him he's going
to be helping us cover how one can
overcome their desires you tasted a lot
of things that are temporary but the
hereafter is permanent so we're going to
be back with him so he can help us and
give us some advice on this very
important topic we'll be right back on
the Deen
there's only one bad Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
I said I love to love peace be unto you
speak unto you Eddie
how are you doing I'll have the love ro
it's good to see look at my smile I got
a big smile because I'm happy that
you're here that I'm here with you
little love I'm very excited to have you
with us again good to be back Allah the
Almighty the creator United this again
and hopefully he'll keep uniting us
Jones were alive and sha Allah I want to
talk to you about many things as many
beautiful things that there are to talk
about in Islam but one of the things
that many of us encounter and are people
who agree with the idea that there is
only one God and that we should worship
Him alone that we should not worship the
Sun the moon and you gave some beautiful
analogies and people can see the show
but how you came to Islam and how you
refuted the idea that God can be a man
the guy could be a woman etc etc it
doesn't go with the nature so when
people understand that this call to
Islam is something natural worship got
some surrender submit to him it's
something that people are bobbing their
hair they say yes this makes sense but
now the action that is necessary to
follow this belief that's where people
many times they don't come to so there's
a lot of desires we feel that people
have and they're in pursuit of the
American dream their pursuit of their
American home the white house at the
picket fence they want to be around the
elite group of people so do you think a
lot of times that this is more important
to people than the truth and how can
they overcome this desire for wanting
the money the prestige and you know what
God's Way of life is just getting in the
way talk to us dad Eddie that's
certainly the truth I I don't think that
the main obstacle
between people and Islam is their
failure to understand intellectually
that Islam is the truth yeah I mean I
think once you examine when you actually
take time to read the Quran when you
actually take a bit of time to read
about the life of the Prophet Muhammad
you know an authentic an authentic life
history of the Prophet written by you
know people who believe in Muhammad you
know not people who uh
what I'm saying is when you actually
find out what Islam is about for
yourself rather than relying upon your
preacher or the newspaper or some you
know trashy news station right who can't
even tell an accurate story about
anything right you know if you rely on
those sort of people about your
information for Islam that's not where
you get it from but if you really study
it I think you will know that it's the
truth so I don't think the issue as you
mentioned it's in our nature its natural
and makes so much sense so what is
getting in the way what's getting in
will in the ways our desires does that's
what's getting in the way it's our
desires it's like okay if I become a
Muslim then I have to stop this I have
to stop that I have to do this I have to
do that I have to change my life and
that's the real issue and you know part
of the problem is is that first of all
as Christians we were brought up to
think that salvation is a bit like
instant coffee or you know it's just day
just but even Jesus he takes all your
sins you know
well isn't that fantastic right just
what will you do anything you like
because Jesus has died for your sins and
I can live anywhere I like because the
the price has been paid
you know vinas easy is convenient and
really if you're honest it just doesn't
make any sense yeah you know nothing
works in life like that and why should
it work with religion you know
no it's desires Eddie you know and and
you see the thing is my role is that you
know most desires you know in Islam the
word for desires in its name is nufs
nuts yeah it's interesting that the nufs
the nots is actually at its very root as
it's very basic
the nufs are actually essential for our
survival they're the things that drive
us to eat to drink to procreate to
protect ourselves so the feeling of
hunger that's from our lufs the feeling
of thirst is from our nafs you know the
sexual desires from our nafs even anger
you know anger is there it's essential
to protect yourself from dangerous
things right that's the you get the
adrenaline and all that that is natural
in order to protect yourself and either
the nufs are going to do one of you know
there's one of two things either it
drives you towards something that is
pleasurable right or it takes you away
from something that is harmful so that's
the two directions you know like
obviously in the case of procreation
sexual desire that's something
pleasurable that drives you in a certain
direction right but anger drives you
away from something that you're you know
I mean anyway this is something anyway
modern psychologists acknowledge that
these things are going on in the human
being and this is what Islam talked
about 1,400 years ago about the nufs so
the problem is not really the nufs
itself the problem is when we go beyond
the bounds when we go beyond the bounds
when that hunger turns into gluttony
mm-hmm right when that love or that
desire turns into lust when that need to
collect something to see us through the
winter makes us miserly and hoarding
makes us hoard so basically our basic
problems is not the nufs itself that
it's controlling our desires so the real
issue here is being in control of
yourself having self-control having
self-discipline right having control of
what's going on inside you yeah now the
real problem at is that we live at the
Western society today unlike almost any
other civilization if you look in the
history of civilization Chinese
civilization the Roman civilization
ancient civilizations the ancient Greeks
all of them considered the controlling
of your desires and your passions and
being in control of yourself as
a goal that is worthy of being pursued
right and it's something that is almost
the opposite in the Western world today
in the West today it is really almost
the opposite it's all just about just do
it enjoy yourself go for it go get it
you know everything is satisfying you
know just just enjoy yourself and
satisfy your desires and a person who
has you know like self control and self
discipline especially emotional control
and emotional self discipline is almost
looked upon as someone like strange and
you know what's wrong with you you know
like just hang loose and be you know
chill out and this is really this is not
a good way to be alright and I mean this
is not just Aslam saying this is you
know this is actually something
fundamentally flawed about the way
society is right now okay
and you know what is really interesting
what is really interesting Eddie is that
I've been reading a book recently and
not an Islamic book it's a book on
psychology written by a guy if I'm
saying is name right by Mihaly chicken
Halley and it's called flow and it's
about happiness they did this
psychological study on how to achieve
happiness and what makes human beings
happy now this is a scientific study
this is not anecdotal they did a
long-term scientific study with
different people from different sections
of society all over the world different
languages and they've discovered
something that is obvious but at the
same time remarkable what did they
discover they discovered that the things
that make you truly happy are not things
like you know having sex watching TV
having a beer with the friends you know
getting drunk listening to music
watching movies no they found that when
people were in were doing those things
they did not report high levels of
happiness people actually they found
were most happy when they were
struggling struggling and sometimes on
the very limit of their ability in fact
the more it was on the limit of their
ability the more happiness and
satisfaction they reported
as long as they were struggling and they
could achieve something that made them
feel they were doing something
worthwhile and I put this to a girl the
other day who I was talking to a body
slam and she basically confessed to me
she said look the things that worry me
it's not that I don't know it same as
the truth it's like I can't get drunk
with my friends and I I can't do this
and I can't and I just took that example
getting drunk I said let me ask you a
question right when you've had a you
know we call it an England a piss-up
right yeah right you you had a piss up
on the town right and you let me ask you
a question at the end of that night do
you feel I've really achieved something
now as a human being I've contributed to
the welfare of humanity I mean she
laughed right but I said no seriously
because at the end of the day you don't
feel that you've done something
worthwhile as a human being you are not
going to feel better about yourself and
how can you describe that as happiness
the ultimate end of it is misery right
and so this is the thing right this is
the thing about controlling your desires
when you control yourself you control
your emotions you control your desires
you have control of yourself this you
know you are struggling and sometimes it
is hard and sometimes it is sometimes it
is difficult but what have you achieved
you know that you have achieved
something worthwhile you've achieved a
noble and important objective right yeah
yeah and I think that therefore in the
context of embracing Islam I'm not going
to sit here pretending that it's all
going to be easy right but I tell you
something all absolutely guarantee it
will be the most satisfying and happy
thing that you ever do in your life
because it will bring you true happiness
true satisfaction now people are
sacrificing each and every day even the
model she's fasting to keep that lean
figure isn't she beautiful example she's
getting up at a certain time getting a
better sense so she don't get the
wrinkles that's right so somebody is
dictating her life what person who wants
to achieve that degree right that person
is in a study circle right he's
sacrificing the weekend parties but
they're sacrificing for worldly things
yeah what do you think I mean the
ultimate sacrifice should be towards the
crater shouldn't I think this is you
know I mean
good point Eddie and the point is that
here is actually I tell you what
okay this gets a little bit more
complicated because someone working for
a degree is almost definitely someone
doing something worthwhile
yeah and they may actually get a strong
feeling of satisfaction and happiness
from that and you real genuine
psychological so these people do tend to
be had they have to have some control
over themselves and over their desires
yeah and I guess that's why until today
a degree is worth something when you go
for a job because the guy knows this guy
sat exams he had control of himself he
had some self-discipline you know so
that person has some sort of
self-control yeah but you know the
interesting thing is what you said what
are you striving for mm-hm and this is
the other thing is that a lot of people
do get some genuine feeling of happiness
from some of the things that they do so
they do strike I mean you know like I
mean you yourself you you you you're
involved in you know jiu-jitsu martial
arts and so on and so forth right so I'm
sure that before you were Muslim you can
relate to that experience a lot of
sacrifice a lot of disciplines but and
there's a huge feeling of satisfaction
that there is right but still there was
something missing in your life and what
was missing in your life is putting what
you did into the context of the bigger
picture right the bigger picture and
this is what they call in Psychological
terms okay they call it you know
ontological anxiety which basically
means that it basically is what am I
here for what's the purpose of my life
Yeah right what is what I'm doing fit
into the bigger picture the bigger
questions of why and how and this is the
thing in the reality you can get your
nice house and you can have your nice
car and you can have your you know 2.5
kids and they're you know all the other
things that you whatever right but you
everyone out there knows that there's
still something missing in their life
right I just want to give you one
example that you know because and I'm
going back to this book that it's really
interesting in this book this guy is
talking about that you know what you can
do is you can string together enough of
these experience
to give your life the semblance of
happiness and what's amazing is these
are the things I was thinking about 20
years ago when I first became Muslim
right I looked at my mom and dad my dad
is a person who I guess a bit you know
he's very sporty person a lot of
sporting activity in his life you know I
remember when he was I think he was 60
65 or 64 he learned to windsurf at 64
learn to windsurf and he was good at it
I mean that's some serious athleticism
yeah but you know he's 87 now right and
you know may Allah guide him you know
he's lost he's losing the use of his
legs now everything that he took
satisfaction from in his life has gone
yeah right he can't do these physical
activities anymore
he can't read because he's gone blind
and one I used to love reading right so
you know all the things that he used to
get this happiness from have left him
and what has he got that all those
things that he invested his time even
the beautiful house he's got he can
hardly walk up and down the stairs right
you know so you find that even his
marriage that he's invested so much time
you know it's not what it used to be so
what has he got at the end of the day
it's so clear that and it's so so clear
to me that now he's and he is now really
you know quite often depressed and this
is the thing that everyone needs to
think about yeah is that you know okay
you've got your dream home and you've
got your dream car but you're gonna get
old right and things are going to happen
to you in your life and then what and
then what have you got so at the end of
the days or it's an empty dream yeah
it's an empty dream that has no real
foundation at the end of the day we are
gonna die and we're gonna meet our Lord
and we're going to meet our Creator and
he is going to judge us right and what
he's going to judge us about is not did
you have a nice house or did you have a
nice car he's gonna ask us about what we
did in our life right what good things
did we do did we worship Him did we
believe in him did we follow his
guidance what did we sacrifice in order
to help others
and I just want to say there's another
thing you know something I always ask
people to think about think about the
things that have given you the most
satisfaction in your life and I will
almost guarantee right that the things
that have given you most satisfaction
are the selfless acts of sacrifice you
did to help another human being or help
another creature right yeah and those
are the things that will stay with you
yeah right
even you know if you even if you got a
gold medal in you know judo and the
Olympics right but believe me the thing
that you did to help another human being
some act of kindness that you did some
good deed that you did to help others
that is the thing that will stay with
you right because it is something that
is really truly something beneficial
right and so this is what Islam is
telling Islam is telling us to be good
people
Islam is telling us to fill our life
with good deeds yeah because that is
what God is gonna weigh up for some of
the Day of Judgment it's simple that
submission that obedience sincerely to
the one God that created Jesus Moses the
Sun the moon everything in his universe
that's the one who can give us peace
that's true and that's summed up with
one word Islam that's beautiful isn't it
tell us for the thousands of people that
are going to be watching there is one
practical situation somebody out there
many can probably benefit from this
man's story that he is coming to the
realization the more he investigates
that this is the truth but we know that
that devil we know his tricks that he
waits in the path of one who's striving
to become a Muslim and he says are you
going to become a Muslim one who
surrenders and submits to God and
forsake the way of life of your
forefathers
I personally spoken to one individual
like this that he's left off the friends
that take him out to the bars and to the
clubs he's leaving this life and he is
feeling good about that he's hanging
around some Muslims and he likes the way
they carry themselves he has a girl
and he wants to know he says she's all I
know now and she might be okay with this
she might not but there's this timidness
now that if he becomes a Muslim what
about what the friends are gonna say
this is a change now that it's happening
he's at their border and he's admitted
that these doubts come into his head
these things about now the religion of
the parents and some of these other
distractions along with the desires what
advice do we have for this sincere
individual so we can give him that
enthusiasm and motivation to continue on
and do that simple step submit to the
one guy I mean Eddie there's quite a few
pieces of advice I would like to give to
this individual I mean first of all I
would probably relate to him my own
personal experience yeah because what
he's going through is almost exactly
what I went through my journey to Islam
and the same thing I came across the
stage when I knew is that was the truth
I'd even actually embraced Islam and
started praying but one my girlfriend
found out she freaked out she went crazy
and I stopped following the religion but
God taught me an important lesson and I
thank God that he did because I wouldn't
be sitting here today if I hadn't
learned that lesson so what happened is
that our relationship disintegrated I
mean I gave up the truth that I
discovered thinking that it was going to
make her happy but really okay I mean
we're talking about a man in a woman
situation is a woman really going to
respect you because you don't have the
courage to follow your convictions all
right no woman's no women did not
respect men like that right I mean in
the short term right she might but what
she wants to see from you right is as a
man leadership commitment following what
you know to be true I mean what what
have you really shown about yourself
that you're weak minded that you you
know that you're not confident about
yourself that you depend upon her like
you know no woman really respects a man
who like depends upon her so you know
even you think that you're doing
something to make that human being happy
but even she won't be happy with you
because the reality is and this is what
the Prophet
said whoever does something to please
people
but it displeases God God who controls
the hearts of everybody will make those
people displeased with you right and
whoever does something to please God
even if that thing is displeasing to the
people
Allah Allah who controls all the hearts
will make the hearts of those people
pleased with you yeah so this is the
reality you have to know that God is the
controller of all the hearts
God is controls your girlfriend's heart
and your family's heart and even the
hearts of all of your people right and
people respect sincerity people who look
at Muhammad Ali look at Muhammad Ali
right here is a guy who was and this is
a living proof of what the Prophet said
and what the Prophet said about Allah
right here is a man who was reviled in
the newspapers right insulted he was
called a traitor why because he refused
to fight because it was against his
belief right but today he is loved he is
adored even by people who are not Muslim
those the people in America the people
throughout the world love him and
respect him because he stood up for his
belief a famous boxer yeah the famous
boxer David could Casius claim because
he stood up for what he believed and
they mentioned this right they mentioned
this even Malcolm X right similarly a
man who was reviled and listened but
still today people respect him because
he stood up for what he believed right
and that's something human-beings
ultimately admire so when you find the
truth you stick with that truth and you
stand up for that truth because that's
part of what is going to make you a
better human being but more important
than that you know you will be someone
who God loves ya you God loves you and
you will love God and the believers will
love you and that's the best thing you
can possibly have now we've just got a
few more points to tell us that were
almost out of time this individual just
aside no real quick yeah they can
actually share Islam with them also she
might come to the same convictions
probably and then there's nothing wrong
that she accepts Islam that they can
come together and marry and do it we
should just say to her you know I've got
something to share with you this is
something I've discovered this I know it
sounds crazy but you don't just look
into it
these things you know because this is
what I've understood yeah right and I'm
a man of my convictions I want to find
something I have to follow it
yeah right be a man you know you're a
man be a man
yeah I have like a man act like a man
you know because what a lot of women in
the world today right they did that they
can't find these real men yeah because
you know what our societies have
emasculated right they've made you know
they've taken the maleness out of men so
be a man but being a man doesn't mean
beating people up and being tough and
match up right actually a true man is a
person of compassion he's a compulsion
of a person of firmness of understanding
right that's what it's strength of
character this is what and this goes
back to what I was talking about right
strength of character it's about the
inner dimension being control being in
control of yourself right being able to
control yourself right being able to you
being in control of your desires your
desires is like a horse right you ride
the horse
you don't let the horse ride you yes you
tell the horse where to go it doesn't
tell you where to go that's how you need
to be be in charge of yourself right now
you've done some incredible things in
the last few minutes talk to us the
importance now because you went from
being a Christian and then you came to
that way the way of all the messengers
of God submitting to nothing in the
creation but the Creator the heavens the
earth and now you're out there and
you're sharing this message this is
rational logical message of worshipping
the one God and helping to clear out the
many misconceptions that people have of
Islam and you're doing some wonderful
work let's talk about some of these
things that you're doing and some of the
importance of people also doing the same
thing of inviting people well I mean my
advice to all Muslims and you know is to
take the task of giving down on calling
people to Islam really seriously in the
Koran Allah said while to come in come
on bottom yonder honor ll Haiti we are
modern I've been my trophy way and how
now in among Curry
while home almost be home which means
let there are
from amongst you meaning the Muslims a
group of people a band of people that is
inviting to all that is good they
enjoying what is right if a bit of what
is wrong and they are the successful
people and you know this shows that it's
an obligation that from amongst the
Muslims there needs to be people who are
dedicated to calling others to the
goodness of Islam right and one of the
things that I have realized although
there are so many people like you Eddie
doing fantastic things like you know our
friend use of estates doing fantastic
things right like Zaki like doing
fantastic things but is there really an
organization that is dedicated and
focused almost entirely on this task
especially the task of inviting people
who are not yet Muslim to Islam I don't
think we don't think that that
organization exists certainly not on a
big international scale so my ambition
is to really not only create because
we're in the process of creating but you
know getting an organization like that
together so we can really give people
the resources and train them and equip
them so that they can learn how to share
this beautiful message of Islam with
others so you know people could check
out you know our beginnings because all
it is is a beginning you have a website
you have a website it's ie RA so it's
i-era as in you know era and age ie
rIDOT Cote UK I mean we're starting off
in the UK so WWII era UK org and you can
check out about the organization there
and show um you know if you need any
help that's what we're there for to help
you call others to Islam in sha allah
now closing advice for that person who
you know what he's ready to step up he
realizes man you know what
I can die tomorrow Michael Jackson died
that's right
Ed McMahon died Farrah Fawcett died and
Bruce Lee died and his son died and this
person died and we will
dai you want to die in a state of
obedience and submission to your create
or give them the motivation that person
to make that crucial step right now well
I think you just said it I mean because
they've investigated they know that they
have to establish the prayer is that
another trigger Shaitaan it is just
another trigger the devil nothing to it
but to do it you know what he will just
keep dry if he can you know delay it one
day two days he is just gonna hope that
that's the day that you die and you die
without those words we got Washington
letter hail O Lord also lot on your lips
that's all he wants what does that mean
that I testify there was nothing where
they worship except the one God and that
Muhammad is the Messenger of God
I would say to him if you know this one
God and you know what Muhammad is the
Messenger of God say it testify and join
this beautiful nation and that would
include all the preceding messengers
Jesus Moses Noah Abraham they were all
messengers they were the way the truth
and the light that's in there too God in
their time and their time this is
realizes the way in the truth and the
light today do this as the key to
paradise it's the key to paradise then
you got to live this life that's right
you got in obedience to God that's it
thank you may god almighty the creator
Allah rewards you and I look forward to
being with you again
and me too it was a pleasure it was a
pleasure thank you very much and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Deen show to find out more about
Islam for those who want to become
Muslims who want to make a conscious
decision without no coercion to accept
the religion the way of life of all the
messengers of God called the number on
the screen 1 800 662 m and learn more
and be brave enough to follow up that
belief that's already inside of you all
you got to do is give birth to it let it
come out don't suppress it come back
here every week to the Deen show and
we'll see you next time God willing
until then assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you the DVDs for Dawa as allah has
said in the quran in surah now 16 125
will do alasa be a leader bookable
hikmah t
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom beautiful preaching and reason
with them in ways that are best and this
is a great opportunity for you to take
up the obligation take up the call as
Allah has told you to do and share this
beautiful message with the world Islam
submission to the one God come and see
what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
God but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to give
up for spring guide this one I would
never give up spreading this message
okay you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow so you got to find that urges
you to do the right thing right now if
you say that you do not believe in Jesus
you have stepped outside of this then
you cannot be a Muslim as attending our
faith too
you
you